diese Männer gehen ihrem Ende entgegen
dem Strick die Todesstrafe für
Vergewaltigung und Mord
sechs Männer die sich an nervaja
vergangen hatten in einem Bus in Delhi
die 23-Jährige starb an den qualvollen
Tod das war 2012 vergessen ist nichts
auch weil der Prozess sich fast ein
Jahrzehnt lang hinzog ist schließlich
folgte was die Mutter Gerechtigkeit
nennt
andere Männer ab
Opfer trauen sich oft nicht zu reden
fürchten dass ermordet werden wie meine
Tochter aber jeder soll wissen wer so
ein Verbrechen begeht wird gehängt
es gibt viele schreckliche Verbrechen
gegen Frauen in Indien keins hat das
Land so geschockt wieder fallen dabei ja
die unfassbare Brutalität ließ die
Volksseele kochen
die Hinrichtung der Täter geradezu
herbeigesehnt
die Leute fordern harte Strafen
erschießen aufhängen aber sie fragen nie
wie es so weit kommen konnte
bis wir nicht die tief verwurzelte
Ungerechtigkeit die Diskriminierung der
Frau erkennen und überwinden kann man
sich die schlimmsten Strafen ausdenken
so werden wir die Gesellschaft nicht
verändern
die Gesellschaft verändern vielleicht
geht es ja so eine Frau 50 Männer aber
sie hat hier das Sagen im Kurs zum Thema
Verständnis fürs andere Geschlecht die
Psychologin ratika ist eine Freundin
klarer Worte
95% aller Frauen fühlen sich nicht
sicher in der Öffentlichkeit das sind
eure Töchter eure Frauen eure Schwestern
wir haben Angst wenn wir da draußen sind
auf öffentlichen Plätzen warum ist das
so
manche Männer benehmen sich nicht machen
Sprüche
ja und noch schlimmer also fragt eure
Frauen Schwestern Töchter wie sie sich
fühlen fragt sie sie haben Angst Angst
vor Männern Angst vor Anmache
Belästigung Vergewaltigung oft passiert
es in der Öffentlichkeit oft sind
Transportmittel Tatorte nervaja war da
kein Einzelfall
wir sitzen 50 Taxifahrer Rikscha-Fahrer
Busfahrer potenzielle zeugenpotentielle
Täter sie sind nicht ganz freiwillig da
die Kursteilnahme ist Voraussetzung für
eine Fahrerlaubnis
wenn wir zum ersten Mal das Thema Gewalt
ansprechen hören wir so was wie es ist
okay meine Frau zu schlagen das ist doch
keine große Sache einmal im Monat eine
Tracht Prügel aber nach dem Kurs
bedanken sich manche dann sagen so habe
ich das noch nie gesehen Gewalt ist kein
Mittel bei manchem sieht man einen
Wandel
wie geht man mit einer Frau um was
geziemt sich und was nicht was kleine
Jungen lernen sollten Respekt wird hier
im Kurs nachgeholt mit unterschiedlichem
Erfolg
einige haben überhaupt nicht aufgepasst
manche wollen wirklich etwas lernen aber
andere holen sich nur ihr Zertifikat ab
ohne das bekommen wir nämlich unsere
Fahrerlaubnis nicht verlängert
rechts vor mir saß zu einer der hat
geschlafen ich habe ihn noch gefragt hey
was soll das
fährt seit vielen Jahren und er hat
schon viel erlebt
Deli hat eine Menge moderne
fortschrittliche Seiten aber auf den
Straßen geht es rau zu ein
Großstadtdschungel voller Gefahren
[Musik]
ich sehe sofort wenn eine Frau einsteigt
und Angst hat das steht ihnen ins
Gesicht geschrieben ich muss sie dann
erstmal beruhigen keine Angst ich bringe
dich sicher ans Ziel hier kann dir
nichts passieren
ja viele haben wirklich Angst vor allem
nachts
70 Prozent aller Fahrgäste sind Frauen
die nur schnell und sicher von A nach B
wollen klingt einfach ist es aber nicht
Mädchen müssen schon acht geben was für
Kleidung sie tragen es ist nicht immer
nur die Schuld der Jungs wenn man nachts
ausgeht passieren dann solche Dinge
jedes Mädchen sollte wissen dass es
gefährlich ist
meine Freundin ist gerade neulich im Zug
belästigt worden ein Junge hat ja
einfach an die Brüste gefasst dann
liefer Weg es ist furchtbar und es
passiert so oft frauen sind in Indien
wie Freiwild
Indien 2022 viele sagen für Frauen das
gefährlichste Land der Welt
35.000 Vergewaltigungen jedes Jahr
offiziell alle 15 Minuten eine die
Dunkelziffer wird weit höher sein
mitten in Delhi mitten im Leben ein Haus
in einer Seitenstraße hinter hohen
Mauern und Zäunen sie schützen Frauen
vor Männer
savitas Geschichte ist nur eine von
vielen im Kern steht immer dasselbe
Problem eine Rollenbild das den Mann
über die Frau stellt er bestimmt sie
gehorcht
im Dorf hat mir die Familie meines
Mannes verboten überhaupt das Haus zu
verlassen nur die Männer gehen raus zur
Arbeit ich wollte dass meine Töchter
wenigstens zur Schule können aber meine
Schwiegermutter wurde sehr böse und mein
Mann auch sie hat mich verprügelt und
weggejagt
die drei Töchter durfte savita mitnehmen
der Sohn musste beim Vater bleiben
deutlicher ungleicher können Missachtung
und Wertschätzung nicht verteilt sein
im Frauenhaus geht es darum dieses
verkrustete denken aufzubrechen und
Selbstbewusstsein zu wecken ein
kosmetikkurs manche lernen auch
schneidern manche den Umgang mit
Computern das Ziel ist immer dasselbe
wir sehen wie sie nach und nach ihr
Leben selbst in die Hand nehmen weil wir
sie bestärken befähigen Frauen in Indien
erfahren überall so viele Hindernisse
und sie kennen das nicht anders sie
können also gar nicht wissen welche
Kraft und Fähigkeiten sie eigentlich
besitzen
Frauen müssen umdenken Männer müssen
umdenken indien muss umdenken der
Aufbruch in eine gleichberechtigte
Gesellschaft ist so notwendig es ist ein
weiter Weg